♪ ♪
>> Sean: DEMOCRAT’S DANGEROUS
POLITICIZING OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
A BIDEN ADVISOR REPORTEDLY
DESCRIBED THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC AS "THE BEST THING THAT
EVER HAPPENED TO NO-SHOW
JOE BIDEN."
I GUESS THAT MEANS THAT HE COULD
HIDE IN HIS BUNKER.
A BRAND-NEW BOOK THAT IS CALLED
"LUCKY."
HOW JOE BIDEN BARELY WON THE
PRESIDENCY.
IN RESPONSE, JOE BIDEN’S PRESS
SECRETARY TOLD FOX NEWS TONIGHT
"WHILE SECONDHAND SHOULD ALWAYS
BE VIEWED WITH SOME LEVEL OF
SKEPTICISM, I NEED TO HAS ALWAYS
BEEN CLEAR THAT SHE BELIEVES THE
FORMER TRUMP’S HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC AND BIDEN DREW A SHARP
CONTRAST BETWEEN THEIR APPROACH
TO GOVERNING THE COUNTRY."
OF COURSE, THIS IS COMPLETELY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN DOCUMENTING FOR
MONTHS.
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE SO CONSUMED
WITH THEIR HATE, THEIR RAGE,
THEIR ANTI-TRUMP PSYCHOSIS,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPATIENT IMPEACHME
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, THAT THEY WOULD
RESORT TO PETTY POLITICS, EVEN
DURING A PANDEMIC.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP PUT TOGETHER
THE TRAVEL BAN, ONE THAT HE
CALLED ZINA POLL AND HYSTERIA,
YEAH, THEY WERE IMPEACHING
DONALD TRUMP.
REMEMBER HOW NANCY PELOSI CALLED
AND ALL OF THAT RELIEF MONEY?
IT ALL HAPPENED WHILE THEY COULD
HAVE BEEN FAIRLY COVERING THE
ONES THAT GOT IT RIGHT.
KRISTI NOEM.
THEY PROTECTED THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THEIR STATES.
ALSO OPENING SAFELY, PUTTING
TRUST AND FAITH IN THE CITIZENS
IN THEIR STATES RATHER THAN
SHIELDING, LET’S SEE, CUOMO,
GAVIN NEWSOM, GOVERNOR WALZ,
GOVERNOR MURPHY AND OTHERS WHO
HAD DISASTROUS POLICIES.
REMEMBER, HE PROTECTED SENIORS
EARLY ON.
AS A PIECE IN
"THE NEW YORK POST" EXPLAINED,
"FLORIDA WENT OUT OF ITS WAY TO
GET COVID-19 POSITIVE PEOPLE OUT
OF NURSING HOMES WHILE NEW YORK
WENT OUT OF ITS WAY TO GET THEM
IN, A POLICY NOW WIDELY
ACKNOWLEDGED TO HAVE BEEN A
COMPLETE DEBACLE WITH A FULL
COVER-UP.
AND HE ALSO SAFELY OPENED UP THE
SCHOOLS, ALLOWED BUSINESSES TO
TAKE ADEQUATE HEALTH MEASURES TO
BE ABLE TO FULLY REOPEN.
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR RESISTED
CALLS TO LOCKDOWN HER STATE AND
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
BALANCING THE RISK OF THE VIRUS
WITH THE MAJOR RISKS OF
DESTROYING THE LIVELIHOODS OF
FOREIGN WORKING FAMILIES.
AND ARE THEY FACING IMPEACHMENT?
NOPE.
ARE THEY FACING RECALLS?
NOT AT ALL.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR, KRISTI
NOEM.
REMEMBER INTERVIEWING YOU A
COUPLE OF TIMES.
AT ONE TIME, YOU SAID TO ME, I
AM FOR THE PEOPLE OF MY STATE
AND I TRUST THAT THEY WILL MAKE
RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS.
YOU HAD ONE MEAT-PACKING PLANT
BREAKOUT.
YOU HAVE HOT ZONES LIKE EVERY
OTHER STATE.
BUT YOU QUICKLY WENT IN AND PUT
ALL THE ATTENTION NECESSARY AND
IT WORKED FOR YOU JUST LIKE IT
WORKS FOR GOVERNOR DOS SANTOS.
>> WELL, I DID.
I GAVE MY PEOPLE ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT I HAD.
I TOLD THEM I TRUSTED THEM AND
GAVE THEM PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISION FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
ALLOWED THEM TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE TOO.
LISTEN, WHAT ANITA DUNN SAID
HERE CONFIRMED EXACT THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR MONTHS, IS
THAT THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
WERE USING THIS VIRUS TO PROMOTE
FEAR AND A POLITICAL AGENDA.
THEY WANTED TO SCARE PEOPLE IN
ORDER TO CONTROL THEM AND THEY
DID IT TO PUSH AN AGENDA WHERE
REALLY THEY COULD TAKE OVER THIS
COUNTRY AND CHANGE WHAT AMERICA
LOOKS LIKE.
SO, WE NEED TO WAKE UP AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WAS
CALCULATED.
IT WAS ON PURPOSE.
WHAT SHE SAID CONFIRMS WHAT WE
HAVE THOUGHT AND SAID OUT LOUD
FOR MANY, MANY MONTHS.
IT SHOULD BE ALARMING TO THE
EVERYDAY HARDWORKING AMERICAN
WHO REALLY DO LOVE THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU ALSO
TOUCHED ON AND IN THE IN THE
INTERVIEW --
THEY BALANCE THEIR BUDGETS, FUND
THEIR PENSIONS, THAT THIS COVID
RELIEF BILL IS GOING TO BE A BIG
BAILOUT AND FINANCIAL TRANSFER
OF MONIES FROM RED STATES TO
BLUE STATES THAT ARE NOT
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
I DON’T THINK SOUTH DAKOTA AND
THE PEOPLE OF SOUTH DAKOTA OR
TENNESSEE OR FLORIDA OR ANY RED
STATE ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
SHOULD BE BAILING OUT NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, MICHIGAN, AND
CALIFORNIA.
>> EXACTLY.
THIS BILL IS BIDEN’S BAILOUT
BILL AND ALL OF HIS FRIENDS.
HE REWARDS THOSE STATES THAT
MADE WRONG DECISIONS, SHUTDOWN
THEIR ECONOMIES, ARE THERE
PEOPLE, AND HAVE HIGHER
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES.
IT SHOULD NOT BE FORMULATED THE
WAY THAT IT IS.
IT IS THE WRONG DECISION AND
IT’S THE WRONG POLICY FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
I TOLD WASHINGTON, D.C., OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN, YOU
DON’T NEED TO GIVE US MORE
MONEY.
YOU NEED TO GIVE US MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND ALLOW US TO
REALLY UNIQUELY RESPOND TO WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE IN OUR STATE.
BUT THIS BILL THAT BIDEN IS
TRYING TO PASS RIGHT NOW IS A
BAILOUT FOR THOSE BAD ACTORS.
THOSE BAD ACTORS IN CALIFORNIA,
ILLINOIS, NEW YORK, WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE, AND IT REWARDS THEM
FOR THE DAMAGE AND THE TRAGEDIES
THAT THEY HAVE CAUSED TO OCCUR
IN THEIR STATE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOUR STATE
IS GOING TO BE IMPACTED BY THE
SHUTDOWN OF THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT SHUTTING
DOWN THE DAKOTA PIPELINE.
YOU KNOW, AND YOU HEAR FROM PETE
BUTTIGIEG AND ALL THESE PEOPLE
IN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
WELL, WE WANT THEM TO GET OTHER
HIGH PAYING UNION JOBS.
WHAT HIGH PAYING UNION JOBS?
THESE ARE CAREERS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE VERY SPECIFIC SKILL SET
FOR.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE IMPACT IS
GOING TO BE FOR THESE FAMILIES
THAT ARE NOW THOUGHT AND THEN
WILL BE GETTING THERE PAYSLIPS
AND LOSING HIGH PAYING CAREER
JOBS CUSTOMER >> WE HAVE ALREADY
SEEN PEOPLE LOSE THEIR JOBS.
WE HAD PEOPLE IN OUR STATE THAT
HAD EXPANDED THEIR RESTAURANTS,
THEIR HOTELS, THEIR GAS STATIONS
TO ACCOMMODATE ALL THE WORKERS
THAT WERE HERE.
THE PUMPING STATIONS FOR THE
PIPELINE WERE ALREADY BUILT.
THE PIPELINE WAS READY TO BE
BUILT AND INSTALLED.
JOE BIDEN CANCELING THAT
PIPELINE WAS THE WRONG POLICY,
NOT JUST ON ENERGY, IT WAS THE
WRONG POLICY ON SAFETY FOR
PEOPLE.
IT’S SAFER TO MOVE THE ENERGY
THROUGH THE PIPELINES THAN IT IS
TODAY ON THE ROADS AND UNREAL.
IT IS ALSO SAFER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
YOU KNOW, IT WAS JUST WRONG.
IT WAS RESPONDING TO POLITICS,
BUT NOT THE FACTS BEHIND WHAT
THIS REALLY DOES TO US AND THE
COUNTRY AND THE INDEPENDENCE IT
GIVES US.
AND I AM ALL ABOUT SUPPORTING A
DIVERSIFIED ENERGY PORTFOLIO,
BUT IT SHOULD BE AN AMERICAN
PORTFOLIO.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
WE CANNOT IMPORT OUR ENERGY OR
OUR FOOD FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY
BECAUSE WHEN WE DO THAT, THAT IS
WHEN THE CONTROL US.
FOR ONE LAST QUESTION, GOVERNOR.
A LOT OF SPECULATION THAT IF
DONALD TRUMP DIDN’T RUN IN 2024,
THAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER RUNNING
AND PEOPLE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I’M RUNNING FOR REELECTION IN
2022 AND I AM REALLY HOPEFUL
THAT THE PEOPLE IN SOUTH DAKOTA
WILL GIVE ME ANOTHER FOUR YEARS
TO SERVE THEM.
I LOVE THIS STATE AND I LOVE THE
PEOPLE HERE.
>> Sean: I LOVE THAT STATE.
IT’S A LOT CHEAPER FOR ME TO
LIVE THERE THAN WHERE I AM
LIVING NOW.
I AM PROBABLY THE DUMBEST PERSON
IN THE COUNTRY THAT IS STUCK IN
NEW YORK.
I WILL LIVE ANYWHERE THAT HAS
LOWER TAXES AND LESS REGULATION.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.